wir leben echten kranken zeiten wladimir
putins rede bei der großen militärparade
zum 9 mai wurde mit erleichterung
aufgenommen nur weil er nicht direkt den
dritten weltkrieg ausgerufen hat der
warnte am mikro vor einer eskalation und
lässt gleichzeitig atomraketen durch
moskau ziehen
medienprofis wenn das eine text bild
schere ansonsten war putins rede
natürlich das erwartbare lügen feuerwerk
russland hat in der ukraine einen
präventivschlag durchgeführt weil drei
sekunden später wer die nato in moskau
ein gefallen oder so ähnlich und seine
spezialoperation ist die fortsetzung des
zweiten weltkriegs ich wende mich nun an
unsere streitkräfte und die miliz in
dornbach sie kämpfen für das vaterland
für seine zukunft damit niemand die
lehren des zweiten weltkriegs vergisst
bravo nie die lehren des zweiten
weltkriegs vergessen nie wieder darf ein
großes land kleineren nachbarn
überfallen unter konstruierten vorwänden
um dort kriegsverbrechen zu begehen nie
wieder ganz wichtige lehre aus dem
zweiten weltkrieg
insgesamt war das ja eine eher
enttäuschende parade eigentlich sollten
77 kampfjets information über die parade
donnern doch dann kommt die absage der
flugshow angeblich wegen schlechtem
wetter
ja sie lachen aber solche
schäfchenwolken sind brandgefährlich
außerdem wurde im luftraum über moskau
eine total aggressive schwarzen familie
gesichtet die haben alle flugschauen in
ganz russland am montag abgesagt
angeblich alle wegen wetter oder doch
materialprobleme bei der luftwaffe
da fällt mir ein kennen sie schon den
neuesten russischen blockbuster
jetzt im kino top gun sie fürchten milde
stoppen
sehr sehr guter film hauptrolle spielt
tom cruise job
ja heutzutage in diesen tagen ist
wirklich gar nichts mehr normal letzten
sonntag mainz beispiel letzten sonntag
sitze ich wie immer punkt 20.15 mit drei
tüten pepperoni chips voller vorfreude
vor der glotze ahnen nichts böses und
plötzlich
[Musik]
liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger die
haben den tatort verschoben wegen scholz
fernsehansprache an das deutsche volk
das hat frau merkel in 16 jahren genau
einmal gemacht meine damen und herren
scholz jetzt schon doppelt so oft was ja
an sich in historischen zeiten auch
völlig okay wäre wenn er denn irgendwas
neues gesagt hätte wenigstens ein satz
den man nicht kommen sieht oder keine
ahnung was interessantes wir
unterstützen die ukraine im kampf gegen
den aggressor
das nicht zu tun hier zu kapitulieren
vor blanker gewalt und den aggressor zu
bestärken
was sollte das denn bitte keiner traut
sich dem kanzler zu sagen chef das
müssen wir noch mal drehen sie glotzen
in die falsche kamera
sie irritiert doch total ab da sind wir
ja
und warum ernsthafte frage warum hat er
so gut wie gar nichts über das leid der
ukraine gesagt aber sich sehr
ausführlich über die sorgen von alice
schwarzer und co geäußert heute im
verteidigungsausschuss hat der kanzler
auch original nichts neues gesagt dafür
deutet sich in sachen gepard panzer eine
waschechte blamage an denn für die
gibt's wohl tatsächlich keine munition
neu
was sollen die ukraine jetzt mit den
teilen machen wäsche daran aufhängen
oder was so was wäre ein aufreger aber
wir sind ja mit anderen skandalen
ausgelastet ich sag nur christine
lambrecht alias helikopter mutti
ist im regierungs hubschrauber mit ihrem
sohn richtung sylt in urlaub geflogen
und das noch lange nicht alles bild tv
enthüllt jetzt jeden tag neue lamprecht
schweinereien christine lambrecht ist
ein sicherheitsrisiko für deutschland
deutschlands aktuell für mich und felix
dem ministerium eine frau die die
rangabzeichen nicht kann sie ist
ungeschickt sie agiert um erkennbar
überfordert ständig ist die in
stöckelschuhen unterwegs am tag der
invasion der ukraine frau lamprecht sich
hat die fingernägel machen lassen in der
verhöre die fingernägel um himmels
willen
eine echte verteidigungsminister darf
sich eigentlich nicht mal waschen
klar jenseits von stöckelschuh fragen
war das natürlich instinktlos von frau
lamprecht in einem der letzten
funktionierenden hubschrauber richtung
sylt zu fliegen mit einem 21 jährigen
der das anschließend natürlich postet
weil 21 ist ein smartphone hat aber die
eigentliche frage lautet doch warum
macht ein 21 jähriger freiwillig
strandurlaub mit seiner mutter
rätselhaft waffenlieferungen bleiben das
streitthema in deutschland achten sie
mal darauf wirklich vor jeder
wahlkampfbühne im land brüllen jetzt
kleinere gruppen frieden schaffen ohne
waffen und gucken dabei voll wütend oft
sind das hat man herausgefunden
tatsächlich querdenker die spontan
umgeschult haben auf putin fenja
wirklich also bestimmt auch ein paar
echte friedensfreunde dazwischen aber
eben auch querdenker die nicht aufhören
wollen sich aufzuregen nur weil corona
gerade pause macht
verschwörungstheorien gehen nahtlos
ineinander über und das kann durchaus
unterhaltsam sein es wird hier uns
falsch erzählt hier hier ist nicht
russland schießt hier ein und macht
rambazamba die drehen sie mal das wort
leben um unsere deutsche sprache ist
eine sehr wertvolle sprache wenn man so
tritt nebel das gleiche scheiße
propaganda wie mit der puren aber ich
frage meine damit corona
mein gott was ist nur aus mendig osten
geworden meine damen und herren
und die afg versucht ernsthaft unsere
neue friedensbewegung zu werden hier
seine original post von bernd löcke
frieden schaffen ohne waffen wenn das
der führer wüsste man damit ja viele
eifeler inklusive unser bernie hier der
sich übrigens selbst für den
fdp-bundesvorstand ins spiel bringt
verbreiten eins zu eins lupenreine putin
propaganda neuerdings halt als
friedensbewegung christian ehring ist
schon seit den frühen 80ern engagierter
friedensaktivist war bei jedem
ostermarsch dabei und coach jetzt afd
kreisverbände die noch nicht richtig
wissen wie das mit dem frieden geht
heute zb in der gaststätte zum debilen
hirschen in wuppertal wir hören mal rein
okay leute lieber afd ja schön dass ihr
da seid
ja ich würde sagen wir legen dann direkt
mal los also wir früher in mutlangen wir
hatten ja vor unseren mahnwachen immer
so ein schönes ritual quasi zum
reinkommen und das machen wir jetzt auch
mal und zwar fassen wir uns an den
händen
wir fassen uns an den händen und denken
ganz intensiv an den weltfrieden und
singen zusammen
sag mir wo die blumen sehen ich bin raus
ja ich glaub den jens wotan geht es
heute nicht so gut schade aber super
dass sie mich eingeladen habt ihr seid
ja die neue afd arbeitsgruppe national
denkende pazifisten abgekürzt nazif ist
und
ich hatte erst verstanden nazis pisten
aber
gut ihr seid jetzt also für den frieden
neuerdings erst mal köpfte ja aber halt
auch ein bisschen schwierig von der
credibility her weil ihr jahrelang für
mehr rüstung eingetreten seit und meinte
unser großes problem ist was das große
problem ist dass deutschland das europa
ihre männlichkeit verloren habe
kennen wir alle wachsamer uns auf und
seine männlichkeit ist weg wo habe ich
die wieder hingelegt
so was wichtig wäre als friedensbewegte
dass ihr versucht neutral
rüberzukommen heißt ihr müsste dann
zumindest nach außen eine zeitlang
aufhören putin geil zu finden
dieter wild sagen eins zu eins kreml
propaganda runterbeten ist ein problem
dann betreibt
die angriffe so dass er versuchen
zivilbevölkerung zu schützen das ist
gelogen die wahrheit sieht so aus
faustregel wer alle häuser kaputt bord
sitzt oft nicht die zivilbevölkerung
neuer vorsitzender copala fordert ja in
russischen medien nord stream 2 wieder
zu betreiben und bernd löcke nennt
annalena baerbock einer handlangerin us
imperialer politik nun ja er heisst doch
bernd oder ich hätte das diese woche
erst im frühstücksfernsehen so gehört
der bundesvorsitzenden europa kommt
daher und eben diese laute radikale
stimme aus dem osten bernd höcker der
hand gibt es gerade wieder gesagt er
könne sich auch vorstellen für den
bundesvorstand zu kandidieren also mein
freund heißt bei parteifreund heißt
entschuldigen
wenn ihr den bern echt in euren
bundesvorstand hole dann können wir die
partei demnächst umbenennen in sonstige
okay ich spüre hier jetzt so eine
latente aggression im raum ich greife
einfach mal auf eine technik zurück die
auch in den achtzigern immer super
funktioniert haben es war die sich uns
gleich noch einen schönen vanille t auf
vorher hören wir zum runterkommen die
boards mit das weiche wasser aber die
maxi version legt mal auf hier
[Musik]
und 2
willst du
keine scheibe gleich
von intensiv wie man christian ihre in
vielen dank
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
eine last
ich hab die schnauze voll
auslasten abo da